so let's do one of these stories that
will probably get everybody upset or
disagreeing in some way shape or form
over the weekend some of the Democratic
candidates did interviews with Telemundo
the spanish-language Channel and the
interviewer whose name is Guadalupe
Venegas of course talked about many
issues including Mexico and when the
topic of Mexico came up he would start
to ask the candidates what they knew
about the Mexican president Oh Berta
Lord and both Amy Klobuchar and Tom
Steyer didn't seem to know that much and
eventually got to the question of do you
know the president's name in Mexico and
neither was able to say the Mexican
president's name appearing not to know
them in clover chars case and maybe to
have forgotten it in Tom Stiers case so
let's check out the clips first one here
is Amy Klobuchar you can see Amy
Klobuchar is widely known disdain for
her staff noticeable when it becomes
clear that she is going to be or has
been when he's asked the president's
name
she looks off-camera to someone
presumably a staffer with that
well-known how did you allow this to
happen sort of look here's Amy Klobuchar
yes uh what do you know about the
Mexican president okay well what I will
tell you is that I will visit Mexico in
the first 100 years 100 100 days 100
days I will work there running for
president you would like to be then um
yeah Democratic candidate what do you
know about the Mexican president no well
I know that he is and elected in the
last few years I don't know him
personally I've met with the Ambassador
and I was actually supportive of the
trade agreement so I worked with the
embassy on that they came to meet with
me and I asked because it's so important
especially Nevada California Arizona
Texas yes her neighborhood itself do you
know anything about him specifically his
politics what he's doing since this
would be the country you would share a
border with well you can tell me about I
just I know that they are neighbors and
regardless of who the leader is that it
is someone that I will work with do you
I'm sorry to ask but do you know who he
is do you know yes I um I know that he
is
the Mexican president but can you tell
me his name no don't you think it would
be important if you're running for
president to know who the President of
Mexico the country to the south of the
United States is because it affects so
many Americans
okay that was Amy Klobuchar and then
here's Tom Steyer also asked the same
question do you know about his policies
I think it's a very like easy it's very
progressive men I'm asking because I
feel like a lot of the times this is our
neighbor to the south and a lot of
people don't even know his name
so you know I forget know his name I
forget but I'm just saying I will follow
this policy I'm sorry - we are Telemundo
and our viewers are Spanish speakers and
you're running for you want the
candidacy to just you know represent the
Democrats but you can't tell me the
President of Mexico you don't know who
the president I followed this look I
followed this election
I've watched what I'm important to know
who the neighbor to the south I do but
like I said I followed this election
from the standpoint of he was he was the
mayor of Mexico City he's a progressive
man I followed this policy from the
standpoint of what does this mean for
him getting along with us what does it
mean for him getting along with a
right-wing nationalist president in
United States of America and how are we
going to relate to that and so to me I
followed that very closely because
there's a real question in Mexico where
are they going with their policies this
was a true change it is a distinct
change it's not it so have I met him no
have I do I go to Mexico every single
year yes do I understand that Mexico is
in a crossroads in terms of how it is
governed and this was a distinct choice
that scared the pants of people of
business people in Mexico in the United
States yes I do
so there are basically three stories
here to talk about the first is the top
level Wow
they don't know the Mexican president's
name now it's true that not knowing the
Mexican president's name is very
different than not knowing the name of
the president of Slovakia for example
who I looked up the name it's Susanna
Kapoor Tova because our relationship
with Mexico is very different than our
relationship to Slovakia our proximity
the number of people who come to the
United States from Mexico
is much greater than Slovakia so it's
not the same but at any point you can do
a sort of do you know the name of
ex-leader question and maybe the person
does or maybe the person doesn't but
with most politicians you would find
someone whose name they don't know and
you can make them not look very good in
the moment I am actually more concerned
with what the candidates know about the
Mexican president and his policy and
us-mexico relations then whether they
know the name although not knowing the
name is a concern so neither clos bashar
nor Tom Steyer remembered oh but others
named steyr later said well I know him
but I just forgot the name all clos
Bashar was able to say was he was
recently an act elected she genuinely
seemed to have no idea about anything
else and she's a sitting u.s. senator
Tom Styer is a businessman he says he
did know the name but he forgot it but
he was at least able to list some of the
background in the prior positions of the
the current Mexican president so even
though they both forgot his name my
reaction is less negative to steyr based
on the totality of what was said than
Klobuchar even though the headlines
simplified it as a Mian steyr neither
can name the Mexican president I care
far less about remembering his name than
about how they understand relations with
Mexico what they would do about
immigration the war on drugs economic
policy to support Mexico trade where Amy
Klobuchar voted in favor of crums trade
deal Tom Steyer I think from what I've
seen him say would not have were he in a
position to do so all of that and
forgetting or not knowing the name it's
something but not all that much when
gary johnson was asked about aleppo and
he said what is aleppo not even
recognizing that it is a city that's
very different right not realizing that
aleppo is a city that's central to
what's happening in syria that's not
this now lastly you have to understand
that these clips are being used by some
cynical mayor Pete supporters Pete was
asked and did know the Mexican
president's name and there's all these
side by sides now going
we're peat names the President and
Amiens steyr can't I mean okay maybe
that's how some people decide who to
vote for
I hope we're making a deeper analysis
than who you can name so is this
cartoony and funny and quirky in some
way yes it is but there's actually a
much deeper issue here to talk about and
that's about policy when it comes to
Mexico this episode is sponsored by blue
Chu one of the things I make a priority
on the show is not to perpetuate stigma
for things that don't deserve it we've
talked about mental health we've talked
about many things where we should all
just be respectful adults period and we
would be better off and blue two can
increase performance and give you that
extra confidence you may be looking for
blue to calm blue like the color blue is
the first chewable with the same
fda-approved ingredient as in Viagra and
Cialis it can be taken day or night even
on a full stomach since it's chewable it
works twice as fast as a pill whenever
the opportunity arises blue chew is
prescribed online by licensed doctors
you don't have to go to a doctor's
office you don't have to wait in line at
a pharmacy it ships right to your door
in a discreet package they're made in
the USA and since blue two prepares and
ships direct it's cheaper than a
pharmacy and best of all no more
awkwardness we've got a special deal for
our viewers and listeners go to blue to
comm get your first shipment free when
you use our promo code Pakman that's PA
que ma n pages $5 shipping that's blue2
dot-com promo code Pakman to try it
totally free blue chew is the better
cheaper faster choice and we thank them
for sponsoring the David Pakman show